welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's keynote presentation
titled new paradigms and moving toward
points of care cell therapy services in
the hospital
i am antonina salcido of labrutz and i
will be your moderator for today's event
now let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
our speaker will answer your questions
via email following this webinar
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i would now like to present today's
keynote speaker dr
robert cruz dr cruz is a resident
physician
at johns hopkins training in clinical
pathology
he received his md and phd degrees from
baylor college of medicine
as a member of the medical scientist
training program he also earned a
doctorate of philosophy
and translational biology and molecular
medicine
dr cruz will also pursue a transfusion
medicine fellowship at harvard medical
school
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
dr cruz you may now begin your
presentation
hi everyone uh welcome to uh
my talk today i appreciate your time i'm
gonna be talking to you today
about new paradigms and moving toward
point-of-care cell therapy services in
the hospital
so i have no relevant disclosures for
this talk
so i'm just going to start by giving an
overview of cell therapy today
homeopath a stem cell transplantation or
bone marrow transplantation is the main
cell therapy in clinical practice
it's been utilized now for decades for a
variety of homeopathic
malignancies originally cells were
harvested from the bone marrow
but today they're mainly collected by
peripheral
apheresis post mobilization of the stem
cells
the cells are minimally manipulated so
hematopoietic stem cell transplant
largely falls out of the fda regulations
outside of tissue bank registration
requirements and reporting
of biologic product deviations
uh moving toward actual fda cell therapy
products they're really
three main fda approved products uh with
manipulation of cells on the market
today
so the first is called provenge by
dendrion
it's a gendered cell vaccine for stage
four prostate cancer
the second is camrya it's a t-cell
therapy made by novartis
targeting a leukemia and lymphoma that
expresses a cd19
and a very very similar uh product
called the escarta by gilead formerly
kite
and it also uh has this ant
uh cd19 uh car on the surface
so let's go briefly over what um
provenge is by
um uh as a dendritic cell therapy
uh so essentially you collect uh by a
leukopheresis which i'll go into more
in depth later from the patient their
white blood cells
it's shipped to a factory where they'll
like kind of expand and manipulate the
cells and try to
activate dendritic cells inside of them
from monocyte
precursors and they'll also add this
antigen for the prostate cancer as well
as a cytokine to get the
dendritic cells active they're then
returned into the patient
usually an iv infusion and the thought
is then the
genetic cells will go to your lymph
nodes and stimulate
a t cell response against prostate
cancer
so even though it's technically a cell
therapy for sure there's actually no
gendermic
manipulation which is a huge difference
from car t
which i'll discuss on the next slide and
there's actually a very short infusion
time since you're just
adding this recombinant protein to the
cell therapy
meaning that you can collect on day one
by a day three or four just a couple
days later
uh the ginger egg cell vaccine is dosed
so car t cells uh what are they
so the car stands for chimeric antigen
receptor
it's a gene that is introduced inside
the t cells to give
antibodies specificity to t cells in
order to recognize extracellular
antigens
and then activate cytotoxicity and
proliferation
um it's essentially well we normally
give antibodies today
this almost puts the antibody inside of
a t
cell and it actually makes it much much
more potent
so as i mentioned before euscard and
camaria
are recognized as cd19 antigen on the
tumor cell
on specifically b cell malignancies and
the two main
indications are dlbcl diffuse large b
cell lymphoma and all
acute lymphoblastic leukemia and on the
right side you can see
how a car works normally the zeta domain
increases the killing and proliferation
and then co-stimulation really drives
that proliferation the maintenance
persistence
as well so cd284 mvp
so what's ahead that's what's available
in the clinic today and what patients
are
receiving the hospitals are coordinating
there's also
an exciting product for b cell
maturation antigen
on multiple myeloma cells
there's been a lot of successful data
and it's looking
like the fda might approve later this
year
one of these products by multiple
companies or maybe early next year
and 2021 so i'll just continue expanding
car t cells in clinical practice so far
on the solid tumors have been much more
resistant to
consistent durable anti-tumor responses
by car t cells
all those is a great area of interest
right now in academia and biotech
a variety of potential solid tumor
antigens and
it's possible that cell therapy
for using car t will keep on expanding
for those
uh indications even further
so how are car t cells made the
particular
production cycle consists of a
leukopheresis procedure
where blood circulated out of a patient
and returned
extracting only the white blood cells
you'll then have a
purification step usually some counter
flow
centrifugal lutriation this is something
that a lot of hospitals already have in
their blood banks
just to kind of uh purify and remove any
of the sarah or other components that
still might be in the product
that product can then be shipped to a
company
or a gmp and a virus encoding the car
molecules added to the t
cells to put the gene inside t cells are
expanded in a bioreactor
uh they're then kind of concentrated and
washed
once the expansion's done and then you
put it into
a do quality control testing to make
sure
you've made what you think you made and
then it's formulated into a product
that can then be returned to a patient
so it's a lot more steps than
uh the average drug to made it's a
patient-specific product right now
or autologous product
and in some ways it's kind of remarkable
that
this whole entire process has been
commercialized
so that was the big overview of car t
i think on the commercial side right now
uh this is for camaria by novartis
uh it's about from the collection side
which the hospitals organized
it's then a two to three week period
where it's frozen
and shipped to a manufacturing facility
for
novartis transduced which means put the
gene inside the
car t cells the t cells expanded for two
or three weeks
and then the cells are returned frozen
to the hospital
and then thawed and infused the patient
bedside so
there's a significant time actually even
from the collection
to the patient getting the product
let's talk a bit more about the starting
material which are the
cells which is really important in some
ways
the studies have shown that maybe guides
the outcomes of the entire therapies
so uh the fact that you're collecting
from patients and it's
a patient specific product really
introduces a lot of heterogeneity some
people have
high t cell counts low t cell counts
maybe they'll expand better in some
individuals than others
and so that's actually a huge
constraint both for the collecting side
and then the financially the
manufacturing side as well
so as i mentioned briefly leukopheresis
you circulate out the blood that you can
kind of see on the right side
and you're only removing the layer that
you want
um so there's the plasma layer the
cellular layer and the reds blood cell
layer
and you can really just remove the white
blood cell layer and
what's even more impressive is the
spectra off via
phoresis machine by terumo can actually
just remove the
mononuclear cells over granulocytes
within that buffy coat layer which
contains the white blood cells
um so right now apheresis is the main
way you collect
car t cells all the protocols have you
having a very significant cell dose that
can be collected with freezes
it typically takes four to six hours
depending on the count
of the patient going into the collection
it's really well tolerated minimal
side effects there's a nurse by the
patient the entire time
monitoring vitals any issues patients
can take naps watch
movies and sometimes in cancer patients
you might need to
infuse some other products post infusion
since
the phrases procedure itself can
sometimes
reduce those components and you can see
on the right there's a patient
getting their t cells collected to
manufacture their car t product
um i am a uh transfusion medicine
physician so i'll be highlighting some
of the roles from the
transfusion medicine which reverses the
lab and the clinical side
and try to understand uh how this
specialty
kind of interacts with this process so
uh
transfusion medicine can assess the
patient and see if they're all able to
tolerate the procedure well
of course you want to know if the
person's eligible to even
undergo car t cell their medical history
contraindications
there are certain constraints with
collection pediatric patients that need
to be
minded as well and certain collections
depending on the health of the patient
have to be done with an intrajugular
catheter which is in the right side of
your neck versus being
collection from your peripheral
intravenous axis
in your arms
so the collection goals are really
dictated by the companies right now what
they want for
make their product typically that
entails like a minimal
cd3 count that the product needs to have
in order to ship and what that means for
the physicians on the hospital side is
you'll need to assess
patients counts going into it and you
can relatively mathematically predict
what the patient the yield will be based
on their accounts going into it
the central challenge is a lot of cancer
patients have
lots of chemotherapy and so they might
not have significant
t cell counts or white blood cell
accounts to even collect
and this is really a concern if you can
even a do the procedure and even on the
low side there might be a production
failure
if they're not a successful product
for the companies to manufacture this is
kind of an open
question the field that's still being
debated is what
when should we do the leukopheresis
collection
right now the paradigms you wait for
referral for
car t cell therapy so that means failing
multiple lines of
other cancer therapies there's also a
delay in insurance approval
carcino therapy costs several hundred
thousand dollars
and this can also delay then the
collection time as well
and an interesting thought is you
collected the t
cells even earlier than the other
lines of chemotherapy you might have a
product that's maybe less damaged
from the chemotherapy and they'll be
able to expand more
and you can almost think about freezing
in uh kind of like people do for
core blood today um but of course that
comes with costs as well and there's
also a question of who would pay for
the banking of car t cells
so what does the cell therapy lab do
currently in car t cells so
um hot many hospitals have a small cell
therapy lab
sometimes it's integrated with the blood
bank
that will receive the cells they'll
perform
any testing as necessary to assure
that has enough stem cells it has enough
t cells this is called qaqc testing
and then the fall whatever the product
uh
manufacturer really wants for the cells
whether that means freezing or shipping
frozen or shipping fresh
or the temperature um putting it in
the canister that the companies want it
to be shipped in
and then what happens when you receive
it they're really overseeing also the
distribution
and making sure the thawing procedure
works proceeds and
successful as well but in general it's
an
important limited role really in the
generation of car t cells
so how could cell therapy labs have an
expanded role for
car t cells um i i would say one thought
interesting is they could have better
assays that could quantify the potency
of the donor immune cells
and that would be very useful for the
field because right now there's as i
mentioned
earlier there's a lot of heterogeneity
in the product
and so if we could somehow test even
before
one ships or generates the car t cells
then you would really know okay this
person actually benefited and they won't
and that will save significant money for
the health care system
and this is a really important area of
research that needs to be
analyzed going forward to see how we can
better predict
based on the product who will succeed
and who will fail
and it's imaginable that in the future
you could really phenotype patients
even before collection as a way to
analyze if they will succeed or fail
so another thought is related to the
analyzing starting materialism many
transfusion medicine
practitioners are pathologists and as a
pathologist
you're well positioned to oversee this
diagnostic testing
biomarkers flow cytometry
even some of the genomic analysis that
really
fits well in the field as being able to
help bridge a lot of the testing and the
patient care process
and in transfusion medicine it's readily
understandable that you're trying to
funnel herogenity of patients into a
standard predictable response
and that happens a lot in medicine every
patient's different
and and certainly our goal for cell
therapy and cartesian therapy we have
every patient have a similar response
and that would really bridge the role as
both manufacturing side as well as the
physician side
okay so what happens after the
leukophresis product is shipped
uh we've talked about it briefly but the
uh there's this manufacturing process
you'll isolate activate the t cells
so that means they're ready to
proliferate and that's actually easier
than to put in the gene
the retroviruses work better or
lentivirus works better at putting the
gene inside cells
the companies themselves will receive
the cells they'll do their processing
and then during their release testing
they'll see if there's any infectious
issues or
make sure certainly that the genes and
enough cells
and there's a stimulation c3c28 which
are
kind of fact you know pathways that
activate t cells
and this process really takes two to
three weeks
um and then there are
a couple issues actually when you're
processing the leukopheresis product to
generate the car t cells uh one is
even though you're collecting
mononuclear cells that consists of
lymphocytes so t
cells and b cells monocytes
to a certain extent so you're getting
other cell populations still
uh one challenge has been uh and there's
also
a risk of getting tumor which i'll talk
about the next slide but
uh there have been a lot of significant
challenges with this one is if you have
too many monocytes
uh in the product the cd14 positive
cells
uh it's been shown that the expansion
won't happen as efficiently and it'll be
really favorable to actually
deplete the cd14 positive cells
uh so this goes to show that there are a
lot of ways that even
you're getting this raw mixture of
different cell types
even if someone's selected by the a
phrases machine
in the product and they could still have
gains from
maybe isolating or removing certain
cells of course this adds additional
costs as well
this is a really interesting case report
from you penn that showed that
if you don't if you accidentally in your
mixture of t
cells and maybe some other cell types in
this example
they had a leukemia cell still
in the bag and it accidentally
leukemia cell received the car molecule
and
as practically speaking you can see on
the right side from their figure
it will cause the leukemia cells
suddenly be cd19 negative since the car
molecule almost
down regulated uh the
c19 and the leukemia cell and
unfortunately
this led to a relapse of the patient's
disease because now this leukemia is
completely resistant to how the car t
cell was going to treat
uh targeted namely the cd19 molecule
so again this shows that the product
itself has a lot of
heterogeneity and it might even need to
be processed as well to remove the
things that you don't want uh okay so
let's say
the company uh got the product process
it put the genes in
past qa qc has enough percentage of car
positive cells
then the hospitals will go back and
receive the product
and this is where a lot of the
complexity of car t
cell uh therapy really happens
so the first step is is a bridging step
where
the patient right before the car t cells
are given
proceeds uh chemotherapy drugs usually
cycle foxamide
sometimes and this causes
lymphodepletion
uh basically really wiping out all their
t cells that already in the body to kind
of make a niche for
the car t cells to grow in and grow well
and expand um
and so that's the bridging now we're in
the fusion step where the
patient's receiving the cells and then
really there's a mix of early and late
care where in the early period there's
this risk
of cytokine release syndrome which i'll
talk more about the lace
uh next slide and then the lake here is
your follow up with your oncologist to
see
uh what's happening and then there's
some regulatory
and billing practices that need to be
done or to follow with heart
patients so the main concern that
happens in this post-infusion period
is called cycle and release syndrome and
there's also neurotoxicity
two primary side effects of cartese
therapy
um they're related but they can also
happen distinctly
um and what what is necessary is
inpatient
often icu monitoring these patients get
extremely sick often with intubation
means putting a tube down their throat
to breathe
for them and then the neurotoxin
cerebral edema has been noted
and really only certain centers
are able to specialize in the management
of these toxicities which is why
car detail therapies today are only
restricted to certain
centers of excellence and the company
and the fda will only allow the therapy
at certain sites unfortunately through
studying
the product and the process of crs
they found a couple of therapies one's
tocalizumab
which can target it's an il-6
receptor antibody targeting l6 pathway
it's been shown to be effective for
treating crs another drug anakinra which
is il1
beta antibody uh removing this
inflammatory cytokines also been shown
to be very promising
in mouse models for both crs
neurotoxicity
and then certainly as clinical trials
provide car t cell patients and
medicines
there's even thought that you could have
prophylaxis with these asians so that
they would never develop crs in the
first place
okay what are the current logistical
issues
and challenges with car t cell therapy
one simple one that is actually more
complex than you think is tracking it's
a right patient
right sample it's a very important
practice in blood banking and
pharmacy and all areas of the hospital
make sure
patients receive the right drugs and
therapy since no different car t
so you have to ship a hospitals have
their own bar coding system
and then you need to ship it to the
companies and they're going to have
their own system
because you can't use necessarily a
hospital system
obviously you have to maintain hipaa
compliance
and having two different tracking
systems is somewhat cumbersome
and then you also need a way to order
car t cells and
integrate it with your emr as well your
electronic medical record system
some elite medical centers um they're
also having schedulers
dedicated to filling a pharisees chairs
uh with car t-cell patients since this
really needs to happen as soon as
possible
their cancer might progress and they
would die and given the fact that
uh there's only so many phrases chairs
and nurses um this can be
a challenge since those schedules are
often full
already for patients have therapy and
it's hard to always keep a chair
potentially open for
a car t cell patient
so uh while these uh therapy
cell therapy logistics are really unique
for the pharmaceutical industry
and certainly not the case of
manufacturing
a large product and a reactor and then
purifying and sending it to patients
they're actually somewhat similar to the
workflow blood links today
and transfusion medicine services
oversee blood banks are really well
positioned to solve these challenges
since they're used to
a donation site collecting regulatory
compliance
um some manufacturing manipulation in
the hospital and then
making sure right patient right product
occurs in any
fda report reporting after that
so i think i'll leave you or i'll
kind of throw out a question which is
how do we make
the car t cell process faster more
efficient to patients so right now it's
a bit cumbersome
two three weeks in manufacturing uh this
refers to
and there's a key metric in the field
which is called vein de vein
time i'll be discussing heavily which is
the first
vein is the collection side and the
second vein is getting the product
and uh so that's a significant
limitation and there's another
limitation just referral
for card t cell therapy which takes a
long time
and insurance is an important factor
since uh
you're not going to do the therapy at a
potential risk of hundreds of thousands
of dollars that won't be
reimbursed so focusing on the the vein
of a nazca
aspect how do we really reduce vein
devein time uh
the first phase i said is the collection
of apheresis second veins getting the
car seat cell therapy back
and this is key because the faster we
get
the cells back to patients the more uh
the costs of the culture time are
reduced the more we even really avoid
the delay of life-saving therapies um
because
we there the patients definitely do die
today
while waiting for their car t cell
therapy product to come back
so this isn't just a theoretical
question
so there are a few different strategies
to reduce vein to vein time
the key strategy would uh
be perhaps reducing the cell dose
so right now you manufacture for a
certain
period because you're trying to expand
the cells or undergoing mitosis every
day
and if you had to sell lower cell dose
required for the therapy you probably
wouldn't need to expand it that much and
maybe if you had trials support this
they could give equivalent results
another thought is you could
engineer the cells themselves be more
potent at low doses
uh and then so it's kind of related to
the first one
you could also collect cell types that
are naturally more potent
at a lower dose with similar efficacy
meaning that you don't have to have such
a long manufacturing time
and then the last one is you could
really move manufacturing
on site or locally and now at least
avoid the shipping times which costs
a day on each side so two days total
so right now the freezes products are
shipped really
across the country two sites there's a
location in santa monica california for
gilead slash kite pharmaceuticals and
then there's a central manufacturing
location
in new jersey for novartis
and the questions here on uh reducing we
need
uh shipping time would be how do we
track and receive the cell uh
the preserve the cells and the products
there's different patient id
numbers hospital and company related as
we discussed about and there's a lot of
qa and qc throughout this process
to assure it so highly complicated
you worry about loss of cells and
shipping even for example
uh then they could shorten the in vitro
t cell culture
so it's been observed that prolonged in
vitro expansion
actually while you get more t cells it
paradoxically
makes them less potent and this has been
shown in vivo and different animal moles
and also in vitro
and there's a kind of an interesting
study uh published in cancer immunology
research where they examined the
potential of c19 car t cells harvested
early or late
in a mouse model and actually showed the
day three harvest
that showed a more robust tumor control
despite using a six-fold lower dose of
car
c19 car t cells whereas the day nine
cells failed to control leukemia
at limited doses uh so this really goes
to show you that there's a the phenotype
is changing of the cells over time and
there could be potential benefits
actually reducing it
uh than what we're doing right now
they also noted as their summary
statement limiting the
interval between t cell isolation and
car treatment
is uh critical for patients with rapidly
progressing disease
generating heart t cells in less time
also improves potency
which is essential to the effectiveness
of these therapies
and in a similar manner you can see this
technologist removing the cells from the
liquid nitrogen
there's been other studies that shown
that these frozen cells post
thaw have also been known in oxbane as
well as the fresh shells
never thawed after collection from the
patient
i should know some studies have not been
able to replicate this so
this is still a hotly debated topic in
the cell therapy community
uh some data to suggest that the dose
could be
uh reduced was this really intriguing
study
coming out of upenn where they
ultimately found that only a single
one cell was responsible for curing and
killing
every tumor cell in a patient
so this really suggests that if you
could modify intrinsic
cell factors inside the t cell that's
actually more important than the actual
cell dose
uh and you can really see that on the
bottom
the single clone which they measure with
the dcr
locus actually expand over time to be
almost consume or become the entire t
cell population
uh really suggesting there's a lot more
to be gained from the engineering
aspects of cartoon cell therapy and
what really comes down to upfront with
the cell dose
if you could reduce deltoids this means
that you could
have a maybe a lower a freeze to cell
collection goals up front
you could also move to what's called
peripheral blood mononuclear cells so
that could just be an iv
donation from your arm and you're not
even
using a phrases procedure or
alternatively it could afford you to
collect a large collection up front
which would achieve cell count goals
quickly
and in a matter of couple days such that
you wouldn't need all the expansion
steps since
really you'd have the product from the a
phrases procedure a lot
so the other aspect to how can we make
this process better reduces cell dose
and vein of vein time
is collecting the right cell types so
significant research has suggested
uh whether the raw aphorisis product
with variable mixtures of t cell types
is actually the best source for
therapies
there's a company called juno
therapeutics which has now been bought
by celgene
that's currently exploring using a
defined
cd4 cd8 ratio in their cd19 car t cell
product so the cd4
the helper t cells kind of uh
orchestrating boosting different cell
type cda
or your cytotoxic or effector t cells
and they're almost destroying the tumor
although
in truth both cell types have some
cytotoxic
properties so they're using also that
this defined ratio for their c19 car t
cell product still other groups are
explored using uh
t cell central memory phenotypes these
are those long lived cells from
vaccines for instance in your body
allowing your immune system always come
back to fight
a foreign invader and those might be a
better phenotype to
put your car molecules in they'll last
longer
the challenge with proposing these types
of therapies
is that it's just adding significant
costs to have the purification and
processing
from the initial apheresis product
rather than just putting the genes into
the product
right away
so the next topic is uh engineering more
potent cells that expand
in vivo so there are several strategies
that may be pursued
in order to make the car t cells more
potent and expand
more after infusion to the patient uh
one is there's something called an
armored car strategy where you can put
in different cytokines such as aisle 12
7 and 15 have been explored
you can think about this strategy is
almost like replicating the
uh the knockout and the tet2 gene that
we just went over in the upn
trial uh you can also find the 41 bbe
ligand as well that's been shown to have
the cartesia
more potency says that maybe you can
have a fewer
lower dose you also put in a negative or
chimeric cytokine receptors such as il-7
receptors pin
car-t cells having better host immune
responses
and finally you can make the car diesels
resistant to host immune suppression
examples tgf beta dominant negative
receptor in order to allow for enhanced
potency
uh and then here's kind of the next
point or challenge is how you would move
cell therapy manufacturing on site so
clearly there are a lot of ways to
enhance the product
and maybe if you moved on site you could
have a shorter culture
and that might make it fresher as well
but i would say the opening question for
the field is if we can really move the
processing time down with these other
strategies to two to four days
perhaps even less do we really need
the entire manufacturing to happen in a
centralized location with all the
shipping time
or could we do the centralized
manufacturing in-house in the hospital
because with this short amount of time
it wouldn't make sense to even do
two full days of shipping go through the
process of freezing if it could happen
really on site in the hospital
so if you think about this this is an
image
from zio farm which is trying to propose
an on-site manufacturing strategy they
made the comparison they have a
model flying cells all over the country
which can really take two days
occasionally
more or you can model where you have a
manufacturing in the hospital patients
are in the hospital at the same time
receiving their products in a very short
time frame
uh so one of the challenge is of
doing what's called this distributive
manufacturing system point of care
system
is that the fda is used to really
approving
drug manufacturing and designated
facilities
i mean fat and you know factories where
you can really expect
every single drug produced to have the
same criteria
and here if you have 100
even a hundred different hospitals
producing manufacturing car t cells on
site
how would the fda and the companies for
that matter
assure that every patient's getting the
right target
it'd be extremely difficult for that to
happen
that said there is a precedent for this
because all hospital blood banks of
which
many are on site manipulate biologic and
sell
products under strict fda guidelines all
the time and give them to patients
regularly
so completely unheard of for instance
that the
uh hospitals and the car t cell uh
you know manufacturers in partnership
with the hospitals might be able to do
this
uh so what are the other uh kind of
concerns or requirements for a point of
care manufacturing
model uh you would need the process to
be
uh you know really to be standardized
and reproducible
most cell therapy labs use technicians
with a lot of
hand-based or manual based protocols and
that creates significant variability
uh the gmp conditions that many
manufacturers utilize are very expensive
and the capacity is very limited
particularly if you're using a manual
process
these gmps are very expensive to build
their specific airflow requirements
um there's gowning requirements to go in
and out
logging materials that go in and out of
the machines
and you know the disposables that the
technologists utilize
uh so this creates a lot of complexity
that frankly
most hospitals don't have the time
energy or
costs really to even entertain
so what's the solution these challenges
how can we
move manufacturing on-site into the
hospital and the solution is really
simple
it's automation and specifically
it's automation that would allow
standardized reproducible methods for
generating
every cell product you the ideal system
would really be a closed system meaning
there's no
open steps that would expose the cells
potentially to
bacteria for contamination for instance
and a closed system then wouldn't have
these airflow requirements
you wouldn't require even gmp facilities
you could have it
you know perhaps in a glp or a
semi-normal room even where
you have a machine that's closed and you
have all the steps happen inside
and part of the proposal as many
hospitals have a blood bank
and there are processes already for
blood products being manipulated and
you could really fit well inside blood
banks even if there's not already
existing
cell therapy uh facility
uh so to discuss
you know a nickname for automation
approaches is called
gmp in a box so you really want to take
everything that's done in gmp
and a gmp you can imagine i have a slide
coming up but
it's someone in a full gown at a bench
and a hood moving and manipulating the
cells
you want to take that entire process and
instead of putting in a small machine
and suddenly these gmp facilities which
cost millions and millions of dollars to
manufacture
would be available to you know maybe
hundreds of hospitals since it'd be all
inside a machine
that a user can simply program and press
buttons in
so how do we build a gmp in a box
for cell therapy and for hospitals
uh the ideal hypothetical instrument
could receive
a heterogeneous a freezes input could
potentially wash it prior that's pretty
routine and standard
and then it can perform the viral
transduction meaning putting the genes
inside the cells
the incubation expansion of the t cell
products
all happening inside the instrument
along with frankly the final
formulation as well the product that you
can actually infuse into the patient
and then the insurance may be acquired
by the hospital-based cell therapy lab
in order to meet
potential demands so it has to be within
the reasonable cost
to be acquired by hospitals
as i was mentioning before gmps are a
hugely expensive operation requiring
air filters protocols make sure there's
no contamination
kind of look at the two people on the
right side to understand what's
happening inside of a gmp
and really only a few medical centers in
this country have sizable gmps to even
contemplate
doing their own protocols and expansions
on site
so if all of them instead of a gnp in a
box with a
unmade instrument that would be ideal
you're
no more clean rooms anymore the no more
extensive training and medical staff
and you again could really move these
activities and integrate them with
traditional blood banks as well
which would be ideal
um and then there's on this broader
problem as well is regardless of cell
therapies other biologics there's
actually not enough
gmp capacity in this country in general
moral stone kettering or msk is one of
the
larger cell therapy active hospitals in
this country
but it's not possible for everyone to
build a large gmp
on-site uh it's millions of dollars to
make complicated even floor plan that i
provided for you on this slide and
even then like at the current gmp uh
manufacturing sites it's actually their
processes aren't scalable
to emit the future demand for all liquid
and solid tumors one day
as there's simply not enough people uh
and
time frankly to make all these cells for
patients
and even in the biotech industry uh all
these cell therapy companies they really
can't
uh scale easily their current models for
making car t
cells to serve a huge capacity
in many different tumors so they also
need a new a new
paradigm if you will a new strategy of
delivering patients
cells okay so what's the current state
of automation now that i've hyped up
its potential if you will uh very much
so
and there are several companies that
have worked on small
table devices for automation of all
steps of manufacturing
i'll highlight here miltoni biotech
has developed the clinimax prodigy which
can accomplish
all steps of cartoon manufacturing from
apheresis input to
final product formulation
uh the general electric has the cepheus
system on the right side for isolation
harvesting
formulation of cells alonsa
has working with octane biotech on an
automated device
for cell therapy uh the clinician pro
clinomax prodigy has the most published
on it so
will be the primary focus for the rest
of this discussion
so there was a study in nature
communications in 2016 where
fred hutchinson researchers in seattle
should use the clinomax prodigy
to process transduce with lentivirus and
formulate
g modified hybrid stem cells really
within one day to a patient
and uh this is really actually they
showed equivalent to
uh bone marrow uh you know manipulation
with
longer previous culture methods as well
and it's known that at least for stem
cells the longer the culture actually
loses the
stem cell like features so this
advantage would be highly advantageous
moving to car t cells a number of groups
are working on this i'll highlight here
a study at the university
of uh wisconsin uh where they showed
that
you could use the clinton max prodigy to
make cd19 car
t cells and also a dual targeted c19c20
car t-cell
using a clinimax prodigy device
so this is already showing that point of
care is possible
at a medical medical center and is very
exciting for
the future of the field uh
here's a an idea or a vision
for the clinimax system if you will
where
you could have the um
apheresis divide apheresis product fed
into
the clinimax prodigy that you see in the
center of the figure and then it
undergoes the cell separation
expansion transduction and then the
prodigy also formulates the final cell
therapy product
that can actually directly be into the
fused patient
it doesn't necessarily by itself
decrease the veined
vein time but
given the fact that it's happening
locally certainly there's no shipping
issues and
if you perhaps engineered the cells or
purified the cells or had the right
ratio
cd8 all those topics that we talked
about on the previous slide
one could then further use those
engineering things to reduce the vein
devein and manufacturing time on the
prodigy
device uh ziopharm
oncology uh is pursuing as i mentioned
before a point of care
uh like trial and a different device
that's not using their prodigy
uh so they are piloting a process where
you take the apheresis product and you
electroporate it
so electroporation you can think about
like zapping with electric field cells
that has temporary holes in it you can
slip in dna
inside the cell so their protocol
outline would be
uh culturing the cells really for like
one to two days after electroporation
then infusing back into the patient
and they're using an il-15 gene to drive
expansion persistence of the cells from
smaller starting numbers
and just to explain a bit more about the
xyre farm platform
again they're making this comparison on
the left side which is the traditional
model
of flying uh car t cells
into uh the tumor
uh or sorry if uh flying car t cells
into uh this transportation site
uh and then to the company manufacturing
uh by the company and then
transportation back to the hospital
as opposed to the xia farm model where
you have an apheresis product
uh then you have the modification with
the
uh gene therapy here they're using a
transposon called sleeping beauty to
integrate inside cells
returning it to the patient and then the
patient immediately has
the car t cell product uh for infusion
uh there's also another platform that's
worth uh mentioning which is uh from
maxcite
company and they're also pursuing a
point of care
cell therapy platform so
i has proposed making car t cells using
mrna
that would afford for a transient
control toxicity
for car t cell therapy essentially mrna
is its transient message encodes a car
molecule but only be around
maybe a day at most the mrna that is the
car
might be around a few days um
so you'd avoid the toxicity since the
the cells would definitely go away over
time
in their model it's similar to zio farms
and that you take an apheresis
product and be collected on the same day
you would um electroporate the mrna
inside
of a car t cells uh and then you could
actually then
give it actually on the same day so
they're proposing within
several hours uh collecting apheresis
processing electroporating a few hours
later giving back to the patient on the
same day
so this would be even the most expansive
of point-of-care
cell therapy platform
just thinking about the practical
logistics of how to
enable point-of-care cell therapy in
hospitals
uh so the prodigy devices cost around
125 to 150 000 right now
which represents significant costs it's
not entirely out of question since
other machines in the hospital labs can
cost
a half a million to up to a million
dollars
and while these devices can do all the
steps of car diesel
production during use no other patient
products
can be run on them at the time so really
like one product at a time
which is a significant limitation this
means for a
protocol that runs two weeks in
manufacturing you can't
run any other patient samples on the
machine at the time
this really makes the shortening
production runs that we discussed
earlier crucial in order to expand cell
therapy capacity
have more patients produced on these
products
and then as far as how a cell therapy
lab a blood bank a hospital
would weigh this as they would need to
predict what their patient volume would
be
in order to gauge how many instruments
to buy in order to then meet the
capacity
on their run times if they know you know
we'll have this
they need this often maybe we'll need
three machines in order to
always have a machine available for
patients
uh leasing instruments is an option to
reduce
costs of course given uncertain cell
therapy
volumes for instance the cost of
disposables will also be important
car t cell companies may finance this
aspect
to deflect hospital costs so if they're
going to
have a point of care platform the
cartesian companies themselves might
actually just buy you a machine and have
it
in your hospital so that they know you
have the capacity to make
the car t cells uh other practical
logistics of the prodigy
um really the the cartesian companies
would still
provide the viral vector so you could
imagine receiving
frozen viral vector that then you would
load into the machine
they could also provide plasmid dna as
well
on any protocols on the machine that
might be a proprietary
for how to make the cells the car t cell
companies could provide
um in fact as i just mentioned before
the companies could really just
finance a machine since uh
the cell therapy products themselves
will cost significantly more than the
machines uh to make them and you they
would recoup their investment quite
quickly
what's kind of unknown if the companies
do buy the machines though
is if you allow other companies to use a
machine
or the prodigy one prodigy for instance
would reserve multiple different
companies
if it's a ladder model you'd almost
wonder if the hospital is better off
having a single machine and then maybe
having multiple companies
maybe pay them for it or lease it or
have some rights in order to
use the machine for production purposes
and while i'm focused on the prodigy
it is expensive it should be cost
effective
when used for cell production runs for
patients to
pay back the cost that said there are
always continuing advances in viral
non-viral vector engineering that might
enable
machine free processes so no
electroporation
no machine manipulation where you just
have a pharisis bag for instance and
then you could add vector to the bag
and this would enable even more
efficient scaling suddenly you're not
talking about expensive machines
and you can imagine i i hear the g
wave bioreactor where you have
circulating rhythmic movement
um this doesn't even require like
expensive instruments
and then maybe even the bag could then
be lightly purified and then given to
the patient quickly
other clinical aspects for point of care
card t cell therapy
so the patients who need to remain
locally in order to receive the cell
products on time
be very important for the patient not to
donate
and then disappear for three weeks when
the car t
cell product needs to be given and if
the protocol would have fresh
products it really necessarily a
compliant patient and
not missing their appointment because if
they suddenly are a day of too late even
they're falling outside of the fda
approved guidance for the product and
they might even need to repeat the
entire process
many institutions now place and provide
bmt patients with local housing so it's
not
unprecedented to even have the patient
a hotel across from the hospital so they
just make sure they'll receive their car
t-cell product on time
and if the patient becomes acutely sick
managing the condition and the vdb or
this
brief manufacturing time is crucial
considering you may or may not have as
much flexibility
you could reasonably have a guidance to
freeze the cells
if need be this is something to keep in
mind
there are uh you know even from a
hospital site
significant commercial benefits of
on-site car t-cell production
saint jude's children's hospital has
already announced and they're probably
at this point while on their way to
making their own cd19 car t-cells on
site
and of course they have a very high-end
gmp facility while training
technologists to
manufacture their products that said
because they have their own product on
site they don't have to pay
high pharmaceutical prices three four
hundred thousand
uh to novartis and gilead for the cd19
car t cell products and they'll save
significant amounts of dollars
and it's an open question if this would
save lots of hospitals money if they
were able to
replicate this model so i'll leave you
with kind of some
outpatient paradigm future
car t cell paradigm so right now a lot
of the care is
inpatient with the symptom toxicity
but if the toxicity could really be
solved most treatments can
actually be done outpatient which would
really change the field and
a lot of the care and complexity that
comes with it
so if there's no inpatient icu stay it
actually
would uh really drive down the cost
rather
so half of the current cost associated
with car t cell therapy
there was one study that suggested up to
a million dollars half of that is the
inpatient cost so removing that would
really drive it down
and then as more patients are treated uh
you can even have lower insurance
charges for car t
cell therapy which might drive down
costs for the field
so a summary of maybe this new paradigm
new vision for cell therapy services
and you have a patient with a cancer
diagnosis referred for cell therapy
my field in transfusion medicine the
physician could evaluate the cell
counts immune phenotype come up with
literally a plan for how to time and
collect
uh the cells from the patient or to have
an optimal
product and outcome and then you could
oversee the apheresis procedure in the
cell therapy clinic which could be both
infusion and apheresis the transfusion
medicine physician
could oversee this in cell manufacturing
in a cell therapy lab
overseeing the qaqc any protocol
modifications or deviations is necessary
this could be any matter of like several
days maybe over a weekend even if the
patient generated on friday
and then the transmission medicine
physician
could oversee the infusion of the cell
therapy into the patient
really monitoring for any immediate
reactions for most cell therapy products
is pretty rare
for those really to relate to the frozen
products in the dmso
and then the patient might even receive
antibody infusion
like tocaluzamab uh as uh necessary to
prevent immunotoxicities before they
even happen
so transfusion medicine physicians can
order then
long-term testing and follow up maybe
the cell therapy and graphene
just to make sure it's still counts are
still there
possibly with flow cytometry for
instance and then the
patient would go back to their normal
community oncologist
and they would then follow our monitor
long term to see if the
tumor regresses there's a complete
remission
and any toxicities outside of the cell
therapy product
so a transfusion medicine can really
assess the patient's
cell collection set goals for apheresis
overseas cell product release
approving dose ingesting manufacturing
time in the lab
and really participate in the approval
of all of these indications result
therapy procedures almost be a sounding
board for different physician
specialties
uh the technologists running the
machines in the cell therapy lab in the
future
fall protocols for a diverse array of
cell therapy products from different
companies
they'll be able to expand of the cells
at a capacity to meet demands of solid
tumor
patients which would be extremely
significant
given how many uh solid tumor patients
there are
and i think the real future is actually
expanding to regenerative medicine
autoimmune diseases
other areas beyond oncology which
represents a huge patient population
that we frankly don't have the capacity
to even
contemplate making cell therapy products
for at this time
and precision medicine can be advanced
into including customized cell therapies
for which target patient specific agents
for more successful outcomes which is
really this model of autologous cell
therapy
so with that i'd like to thank you for
listening
and i appreciate your time and i hope
you've learned a lot
about cell therapy today thank you
thank you dr cruz for that outstanding
presentation
for additional informative presentations
view our agenda on our events page
as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email
thank you again for your participation
until next time
bye